my name is Madeline so I'm one of the
developers of Wolfram system owner at
all from a score in Sweden this is the
talk Wolfram system older in the cloud
with the subtitle integration with
Wolfram language so let's get started
I'm first going to have a short
introduction then I'm going to talk
about having system modeler simulations
in inside the Wolfram language then a
little bit a little bit about the
simulations in in Wolfram cloud and at
the end I'm going to talk a little bit
about deploying models for easy
consumption so let's get started as an
introduction this is a preview nothing
you will see here is going to be final
nothing is shipping so expect stuff not
working expect crashes I would be
surprised if everything works all the
way through with that said we welcome
feedback if you're interested in
deploying your simulations to the cloud
running stuff in Wolfram language talk
to me after after after this
presentation and we'll incorporate that
going forward so let's get started so
this is how something could work today
so let's say Alice she buys system only
because she wants to model something
cool like a helicopter so she buys
system modeler she creates a very cool
model / helicopter and then she wants to
share this helicopter model with Bob who
wants to run a couple of different
scenarios so Bob also by system honor to
be able to run them all and he done runs
his scenarios for example he wants to
check how thick should blades be how
fast should they be rotating for the
whole thing to fly so that's what we
basically have today so we have a
mathematica pick package that shipped
with system modeler so you get analysis
and simulation inside Mathematica
you do need a full system modeler
installation behind the scenes you do
need to buy it currently to do
simulation and analysis of these models
in Mathematica what we have planned is
to make system modeler simulations built
in part of the Wolfram language so what
what that means is when you buy
Mathematica for example you get a
version of the system modular colonel
what's running behind the scenes with
with Mathematica with the Wolfram
language and you get a deeper
integration into delong language and of
course it means that anyone that has
Mathematica can run your models you have
created in the system aller so for our
scenario that means Bob doesn't have
devices to modeler anymore you can just
take this cool holla helicopter model
and running scenarios in Mathematica and
of course if something is in Wolfram
language it will end up everywhere the
Wolfram languages which also means the
Wolfram cloud products well there are
some security details I mean you can do
all kinds of stuff in model like run c
code of course you can allow that on on
the public Wolfram cloud and there are
some infrastructure adaptions but pretty
much it's in the Wolfram language it's
going to be on the cloud so what this
means for sister modeler and sister
modeler simulations and models is that
everything of that is going to be
available in cloud notebooks and that
opens up a lot of possibilities for
example it can now access simulations of
system modeler models on all kinds of
devices like everything that has a web
browser or even your iphone or ipad so
we get another person in our scenario
carol she can she can run some
difference in areas but she just wants
to run a couple of scenarios with this
helicopter model she doesn't care about
installing desktop mathematica she just
wants to run a fuse and eros he just
opens her web browser and runs its these
scenarios in any web browser in the
cloud notebook
so I have a little ? here so let's hope
it we can actually have a live demo with
all the Wi-Fi here so see if i can
actually magnify this as well so this is
just Firefox it's running a tab here
with a wool from cloud or a special
version of it actually and what you see
here is a bunch of commands for
interacting with system modeler models
and simulations so I'll start by loading
the package that is not going to be a
package once it's integrated but we're
not there yet so I'll have to load this
package and this is just to see if
everything yeah everything seems to be
working so i could get system equations
for this hello world model is just a
very simple equation so stuff you can do
with this integration is for example if
you have a model of an inverted pendulum
you get the diagram for that and it has
to go through server and fetch the
diagram but once it does that you get
the diagram so you have your motor you
have a controller gear and you're
paranoid pendulum so everything this I
mean you have evaluate everything in
your web browser but you get it running
running on the cloud so you don't need
to install anything on your computer but
of course you can can not only look at
diagrams you can also simulate stuff by
doing wsm simulates and you get a
simulation data object back and you can
plot stuff from that for example the
pendulum position and I actually yeah
the pendulum position and this
controller switch one dot y cryptically
enough is the reference point for this
pendulum position so you can see it
following the reference point which
changes with steps up and down with some
overshoot but the controller is pretty
good so that's one of the things you can
do you can also do other stuff like take
this model of a axis that rotates but
a little weak so it's going to start why
braiding I can linearize that model you
get state space object out and you can
do a bode plot for example whoops and
see see what the resonance Peaks are so
you probably should look to it that it
doesn't rotate at like this speed
because that would not be good for your
axis so this is the kind of analysis you
can do in any Wolfram language product
once we release this so the first live
demo went okay let's move on here are
the backup slides so another thing you
can do is when you have all of this in
the cloud infrastructure get a lot of
things for free so to speak things you
could do you can create the simulation
API just as in simple URL when you call
it with parameters you get something
back like data from a simulation or a
plot of a simulation result with your
specific parameters you can easily share
your work with other users you can just
send them the link to your cloud
notebook or deploy something to to to
the cloud and share share the link with
them they can access it access it on any
device or you can embed simulations in
your own web pages so say you want to
present your results of your helicopter
model you can have a whole web page
describing your helicopter and just
embed the simulation results right there
they can even be interactive so the
people person who reads this web page
can drag some sliders and see what
different parameters will how they will
affect the helicopter and that's the
last point deploy interactive
simulations on the web so get another
person then he has to sign off on this
final helicopter so he wants to check
the final scenario what what will
actually happen when you run this
scenario
and he definitely doesn't want to
install Mathematica because he is always
busy and he only has his phone with him
so he can just check this on his phone
because it's all deployed in the cloud
so time for the second live demo here i
am a bunch of different pages showing
different examples so here's one example
if we look up here unfortunately i can't
magnify that but it's basically a web
address with the object name and then it
has a bunch of parameters it says time
equals 150 and pipe length equals 1 so
this simulates two tanks that are
connected with liquid in them there is a
connection pipe in the bottom and one of
the tanks is leaking so these two
parameters they say how long do you want
to simulate and how long is this pipe
going to be that connects the two tanks
so for example I can make the pipe
longer and just reload the page with the
other parameters and I get a different
simulation but now it didn't actually
reach any kind of steady state so I need
to simulate it for longer so let's
simulate for 300 seconds instead of 150
and it does the simulation and returns
the plot so that's an example of an API
where you can easily run simulations on
on a predetermined number of parameters
you know which parameters you are
allowed to set and you can just call
them and this can be used in
programmatically from other languages
for example but you can also do it
interactively with the form for example
so this is the same example but now you
have a forum with this lighter can
choose to pipe length and you can choose
the simulation time for example under 50
yeah and then you just run simulation
and you get a plot back same way if you
want to do it again you can go back and
try something else and here you can
probably use the thing that's even
showed yesterday on keynote the outer
auto updating auto submitting form so it
didn't get to another page
another one okay let's see if this works
is actually an interactive manipulate so
you can run simulations in the
background where you drag your slider
and let's hope it updates should update
maybe not let's try a refresh yep you
can drag the slider and it will update
the plot and what it does when you
release the slider it's actually doing
in doing a completely new simulation in
the cloud and just returning the results
to you so that way you can quickly check
different configurations on what the
result will be and I wanted to show this
but it doesn't seem to load the right
thing in my embedding so the idea is you
have your own custom HTML page and you
just embed one of these many plates
inside it right so I'll just skip that
one okay actually I can show the
screenshot because I have backups so
this is what the what it's supposed to
like look like so it's a custom page and
you have this manipulate inside it just
right in the middle of your page and you
can drag the slider and 3d part was
supposed to update thank you for
listening